- [Murali] Hello.
Good morning everyone.
I hope everybody's doing good.
Thank you for joining our code talk today.
Today let's see how
member-owned financials
can use agentic AI to improve
their member experience.
I am Murali Ramanathan, Senior
Solutions Architect at AWS.
- [Mrudhula] I'm Mrud Balasubramanyan.
I'm a principal solutions architect.
We work with AWS not
for profit financials.
So how many of you here are
from member-owned financials?
Awesome.
Is it credit unions?
Insurance?
So how many credit unions?
Just one.
How about insurance?
Awesome.
You guys outnumber.
Any other member-owned?
Which one is that?
- [Murali] Oh, nice.
- [Mrudhula] Okay, cool.
Welcome all.
You're definitely hardcore
if you're showing up
for the very first session of re:Invent.
Hopefully we can get you
off to a great start,
and get you a lot
of value out of this
session for your time.
- All right.
- So, off to you.
- [Murali] Yeah.
In today's session let's see the art
of possible where we'll be
showing how we can use agentic AI
for loan origination system,
and which will have the
member-owned financials,
process loan applications
in a much quicker manner,
thereby increasing member satisfaction
and experience as well.
And this solution we are
going to show today is built
on AWS AgentCore
for which Mrudhula is going to talk
about the features of it.
- [Mrudhula] Awesome.
So how many of you here have heard
of Amazon Bedrock AgentCore?
Awesome.
And have you actually
tried working with it?
Okay, not yet.
Okay, so you're in a good place.
So the idea for the code talk today
is to demonstrate a
working, completely working,
end-to-end solution that was
built using AWS Strands agents.
Anybody heard of Strands?
Awesome.
Anybody using other frameworks?
Agentic frameworks?
You can just call it out.
- [Audience Member] AutoGen.
- [Mrudhula] AutoGen, okay.
Anybody LangGraph?
TRUE AI.
Okay.
Yep, there you go.
So no matter which agentic
framework you work with,
and we are very aware
there are many of them
and there are probably more coming.
AgentCore, which is kind of the,
it was launched last re:Invent
and became generally
available mid-October.
So this is essentially
a comprehensive agentic platform on which,
so the solution that we are
going to be showing you today,
this is the agentic loan
origination system that many of you
in credit unions and banks can relate to.
This is just an example of,
but it's an enterprise-grade production,
almost production-ready solution
that was built using Strands Agents
and then deployed to AgentCore.
So before we get into the architecture,
we want to kind of give you a,
let's get the basics
out of the way, right?
What is AgentCore?
So that when we go into the code
and show you what how it works,
you know exactly what it does.
So Bedrock AgentCore, like I said,
it's a comprehensive agentic platform.
Their you can essentially
deploy and manage your agents.
It's agnostic to the models that you use
for building your agents.
It's agnostic to the
frameworks that you use
for building those agents as well.
Has a few key components
which I'll go through quickly.
There's AgentCore runtime
which is essentially the
serverless component,
it's the compute where
you deploy your agents
as container applications.
And then you have agent memory.
So especially with agents,
you might start off with a single agent,
you might grow into multiple agents,
you could have multi-agent collaborations.
So the idea is that you have
a managed memory component
that you can associate with your agent.
This can be either short-term memory
that enables those
multi-turn conversations.
But also if you're working
with multiple agents,
you can have longer term memory as well,
because this then spans multiple sessions
across multiple agents.
So agent memory code is
essentially that capability
of bringing that short-term memory
as well as long-term memory
to your agent applications.
And then another piece that
we're gonna be talking about
and that we used in our
solution is AgentCore Gateway.
How many of you have heard of MCP?
Does that ring a bell?
Awesome.
You wanna call out what it stands for?
- [Murali] Awesome.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah.
So AgentCore supports
these open-source protocols,
definitely Model Context Protocol, MCP.
And that's really where
AgentCore Gateway shines.
That's essentially your managed
MCP server that you can use
as kind of that unified interface
that your agents can
communicate with tools
that are set up as targets
behind that AgentCore gateway.
And you can have, you
might have existing APIs
in your organization.
You could have other applications
which you might make an API call to
using a serverless compute like Lambda.
So essentially you can have
a Lambda function running
as an MCP tool, behind that gateway,
you can have your existing APIs.
So it supports open API schema
or Smithy models on the backend.
So all of those existing resources
can essentially be MCP-fied,
if I might use that,
behind that gateway.
So that's really what that is.
It's that MCP interface.
So we are gonna be talking
about that as well.
So we covered Agent runtime,
which is the compute,
the gateway, which is
that managed MCP server,
and then the memory, and then
there's the identity piece.
So any enterprise-grade
application definitely requires
end-to-end authentication authorization.
And that AgentCore identity
is that agent-managed identity service.
It centrally Manages the
inbound and outbound auth.
What that means is as you
have your users' applications
that are accessing an agent,
and the agent is making
calls to all those tools,
or in our case we actually have A2A,
so agent to agent communication
is what we're gonna be using
in our multi-agent
collaboration application
that we're gonna show you.
That inbound and outbound
auth is centrally managed
by AgentCore identity which
is seamlessly integrated
with the compute, which is the runtime.
So all of those different
pieces coming together
to help you build a scalable, secure,
enterprise-grade agentic application.
So over to you.
- [Murali] Thank you.
Thank you, Mrudhula, and
this was great explanation.
I wanted to add a couple of more things.
You are also seeing something
called as AgentCore Browser
and AgentCore Interpreter.
These are the tools AgentCore offers.
AgentCore Browser gives you the ability
for the agents to browse
websites on your behalf,
then get the results and process them.
AgentCore Interpreter
gives you the ability
for the agents to run complex create
and run complex code
at the runtime itself.
What that means is you need not write code
which an agent needs to
call and maintain that code.
You can just define
and say what code you want
the agent to create and run.
The agent will do that.
We will see in the example now.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, so one
other thing that I want
to add quickly is typically with agents
and agentic applications,
you tend to think of them
as black boxes.
So visibility into what
those agents are doing,
that observability aspect, right?
So the three pillars of
observability, the logs,
the metrics, the traces,
all of those are super important
so that you can trust the
system that you built.
And that's where AgentCore
Observability comes in.
It supports OTel.
So that's your OpenTelemetry,
and it's integrated with AWS CloudWatch,
if you're familiar with that.
So you can essentially
see at the session level,
at the trace level, as well as the SPAs.
So the granular aspects
of your entire trace,
end-to-end request flow,
and the response flow
of your agentic systems,
all of those can be seen
and dashboarded using the OTel logs
and metrics that come out
of AgentCore Observability.
So I want to point that out,
because that's a big piece of
putting these agentic systems
into production.
- [Murali] Awesome.
- [Mrudhula] Yes.
It's a first party tool, yes.
- [Murali] It's a first party tool.
Now let's, I'll walk you
through the architecture
of the solution we built.
Then we'll show a demo,
and then we'll walk you through the code
of the agents as well.
Now here you're seeing the architecture
of the loan origination system
we built using agentic AI.
Let me walk you through
that from left to right.
On the left, you would
see the document upload,
where an applicant uploads there
all of the documents needed
for processing the loan.
As soon as those documents are uploaded,
they come and land on an NS3 bucket.
And once they land on an NS3 bucket,
a Lambda even fires off
and then calls what we call
as the supervisory agent.
Then the supervisory agent
here is tasked with the role
of saying, "You are a supervisor agent
who will be processing loan applications."
And one of the tasks the
supervisor agent would have
is it has to find out what
other agents are there
which can work along
with the supervisor agent
to perform this loan
application process workflow
and then work with them to
get the whole task done.
The supervisor agent, then
using the A2A protocol,
reads the agent cards of
all of the available agents
and then finds out
that there are three
agents it can work with.
The document agent,
the credit risk agent,
and the compliance agent.
Once it decides what
agents it can work with,
then it creates a workflow.
And then as an action item
it calls the document agent
with the information of where
the documents are located.
Now the document agent whose role
is to validate the documents
and also extract the
information from the documents,
knows that it can
validate the information,
but it does not have the
data extraction capability.
Then again using A2A protocol,
it reads the agent cards
of all the other agents
and finds out which agent
has the document extraction capability.
And that's the bedrock
data automation agent here,
and then gives it to that,
passes that information to that agent.
Then that agent has been
tasked with the role
of saying, "You are only
to extract information
from documents using whatever
tools are available to you."
Now this document agent, extraction agent,
then uses the AgentCore Gateway
and does a semantic search
of seeing what tools it
can use to extract data
from the documents.
Then it sees that it has access
to Bedrock Data Automation.
And Bedrock Data Automation is AWS service
which extracts data
from documents images in an
intelligent way using AI.
Now here we are showing
the art of the possible
where the Bedrock Data Automation
agent is accessing the BDA
or the Bedrock Data Automation
using AgentCore Gateway
which is simulating an
MCP what you would have.
So in a real world scenario,
you may not even have a
Bedrock Data Automation agent.
You may have your own data
extraction software running,
and the agent which is connected
to the AgentCore gateway
as an MCP server,
and your Bedrock Data Automation agent
will automatically connect
to it for data extraction.
Once the data is extracted,
then it gives it back
to the document agent,
and the document agent then
performs all the validation
to ensure that all of the data needed
for processing the loan is there.
Once it performs a validation,
it gives a status check
back to the supervisor agent
along with the data,
saying, "The data validation
is passed or failed."
The supervisor agent, as part
of the workflow it built,
it then decides if the
data validation is passed,
then it'll send it further
down to the credit risk agent
and the compliance agent
for further processing.
But if the data is not there,
using the code interpreter tool as a tool,
it'll again send an email back
to the applicant saying,
"There is information missing
from your loan application.
Please provide all of this information
for processing the loan
application further."
Once all of the information is validated,
then the supervisor agent,
as part of its workflow then
will, using A2A protocol,
then gives the information
to the credit risk agent
and the compliance agent
for credit risk processing
and compliance checking as well.
Now here the credit risk agent
using the code interpreter
as a tool, it calls the credit
risk machine learning model
which does the actual
credit risk assessment.
In this demonstration,
this ML model is stored
in an NS3 bucket that
the agent builds code
on the fly using code
interpreter to download it
and then interact with it
to perform the credit risk assessment.
In a real world scenario,
you will be using the code interpreter
to actually call a sagemaker endpoint
or wherever your ML model is
and interact with it to perform
the credit risk assessment.
And the same way the compliance agent
using the code interpreter
tool builds code
on the fly to perform the
compliance agent checks
and then passes all the information back
to the supervisor agent.
The supervisor agent then
gets all of this information
and then uses its decision
logic which we have provided
in the prompt as a standard
operating procedure
for the supervisor agent,
and then decides to
either approve the loan
or put it under manual review
or disapprove the loan.
Once it performs a decision,
then using the code interpreter again
and using Amazon Simple Email Service,
it sends an email to the
applicant informing the status.
And also it creates a PDF document
of what the loan application
was, all of the details,
and uploads it to an NS3 bucket
so that the underwriter
can review that document
and then perform the
final decisioning as well.
So this way, with this solution,
we are making the
underwriter's job very easy.
We are making sure when the underwriter,
when he has the information,
he has all the right information,
and he can quickly assess that information
and whether approve
or disapprove the loan
based on the criteria.
Now let's go ahead
and see a demonstration of this solution
and then we'll walk you through the code
and how we built that.
- [Mrudhula] Switch the demo.
- [Murali] Yeah.
- [Mrudhula] Yes.
- [Audience Member] You have the model.
This is something, can we
also implement with the MCB,
because what is the feature
engineering that is to be done?
How is it, how does the agent decide
what features it has to extract what is?
- [Mrudhula] So in this case,
we are using the MCP, the model,
for just simply inference purposes, right?
So we're not actually
training, or you know,
feature engineering
data to build the model.
So in this case it's already a built model
that's been deployed.
Yes, yes.
- [Audience Member] For the agent,
how I'll it know what features to extract?
- [Murali] Yeah, that's a good question.
So basically you can have your
own model as an MCP server,
and in the document,
in the credit risk
assessments agents' prompt,
you would define there as a
standard operating procedure,
like what features you
would be need to passing on,
what features you'd be expecting it.
Using that, it'll build the code
and then interact with the model.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah.
So as you set that up,
I can clarify further.
So prior to getting into
the credit risk evaluation
or credit worthiness check, before that,
there is another agent
in the workflow which
is the data extraction.
So in the demo, you'll
see, if you're ready,
you can just go ahead with that.
- [Murali] Yeah.
- [Mrudhula] And I'll explain to you more.
- [Murali] So here I'm playing
now and I'm playing the role
of an applicant where I'll
be uploading the documents.
And because this is a demonstration,
we are not going the process
of using a chat window
and uploading all the information
as that will take time.
So I'm uploading the loan application,
I'm uploading the pay
stub, bank statement,
employee verification, tax returns,
and all of these are
demo data, by the way.
I have now uploaded my lone application
as an applicant.
Now let us see what
happens in the backend.
Now we are using, as Mrudhula explained,
using AgentCore Observability.
From the logs,
we would be seeing how the agents
are processing the information.
Now we are seeing
that the supervisor agent
has discovered all of
those specialized agents,
and then it is sending the workflow,
starting the workflow
by sending the document
to the document agent
for verification.
Then the document agent then
knows that it has to verify
and extract the data.
Now it is searching
for what are the agents
which can do the document extraction.
Then it found the right agent,
which is the document extraction agent,
then it gave that information
to the document extraction agent.
And the document extraction
agent now is using a tool
to communicate with the
Bedrock Data Automation
to extract data.
It'll take a minute
or so for the data
extraction to come back.
- [Mrudhula] And I want to add that all
of this is being done using A2A protocol.
So that's the design pattern that we chose
for this particular solution
because it gives us the most flexibility
in terms of demonstrating
at an enterprise-grade where you have.
- [Murali] Sorry to
interrupt you, Mrudhula.
The document agent came
back with the response,
and now the document
validation agent would now take
that process back,
and now it'll be
performing the validation.
Sorry, go ahead.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, no, I was saying
that A2A is really good
when you have, you know,
you might have a handful of
agents now using a few tools,
but then as you start
adopting, building more,
you could be buying,
you could be building agents.
So you soon might have a lot
of different agents using
a lot of different tools.
So like N tools using M number,
of N agents using M number of tools.
So it really becomes a huge matrix.
So A2A helps you,
because it's doing the work for you
in terms of discovering
the agents that are already
in your enterprise using an open protocol.
Agent to agent, right?
So that's the one we choose.
- [Murali] Yep.
Now the document has validated,
and it is passing all of this information
back to the supervisor agent.
And the supervisor agent now has seen
all of that information,
and is now passing it
to the credit risk to the
compliance agent in parallel.
Again, as you would
see from the code here,
we are not defining here
for any agents like the supervisor agent
or the document agent,
you should use that particular agent.
It is able to decide
on its own using the workflow
which agent it has to
use for the processing.
Now you see here, the
compliance agent has been done
and the credit risk agent,
it's now processing it
using the code interpreter.
You'd see that it is downloading
the model from the S3,
then it's interacting with the model
to perform the credit risk assessment.
Again, all of this,
it's building the code on the
fly and then executing it.
- [Mrudhula] Yep.
And while we are on the credit risk,
to answer your question,
so once the data has been
extracted from the forms,
you now have the information
that you need to send
in the request to the model.
So those are the features,
and those are all based on prompt.
Yeah.
- [Murali] Here the
credit risk has responded
that the ML model predicts
a 98.3% probability
of a successful loan repayment.
Now, the supervisor agent has
got all of this information.
Now it's processing its decision logic
to say whether should I approve the loan
or not, disapprove the loan.
Any questions?
I know it may be a lot to take in,
but if you have any questions,
please let us know.
- [Mrudhula] Yes.
- [Audience Member] Do
you have thresholds set
on BDA where you're saying
confidence score needs
to be a certain level before
it's passed back to agent?
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, you
certainly can do that.
I think we are using
some default thresholds
on the back end, but BDA,
if we keep calling it BDA,
but it's actually Amazon
Bedrock Data Automation.
It's a feature of Bedrock,
and this is a capability
where you can essentially extract data
using your custom blueprints.
So in this case, like Murali was showing,
we have used five different
documents that are pertinent
to a loan application.
But you could have, using
Bedrock Data Automation,
you can essentially work
with multimodal data.
So that can be text, images,
video, what have you.
And then you can specify blueprints,
which is essentially the schema
for kind of the overlay on your data
so that you extract
only the specific fields
that you care about.
And then because it's AI-powered,
it's going to come back
with explainability
in terms of the probability
for essentially the accuracy
of extracting that information.
So you can then use your business rules
to decide what the threshold should be.
And that's also a good,
that threshold is the
criteria that you would set
to maybe incorporate a human in the loop
if you feel that it's below the threshold.
And typically something for
like credit decisioning,
you do want to have a human in the loop,
because especially if it's
a deny, not an approve,
you want to make sure your loan officer
takes a good look at it,
looks at the probabilities
of the information that was extracted,
and use that as the basis
to see why it was approved or denied.
That makes sense.
- [Murali] Yeah, and here you see
that the supervisor agent
has completed the workflow
and it has given a final
decision of approve.
And it's showing all of
the workflow summary.
Now, all of these you are
seeing is in the Observability,
which is on the CloudWatch logs.
So anytime you know you want to check,
trace back what happened for
a particular application.
What were the steps the agents took,
how did they arrive at the decision?
All of them are there for audit purposes,
and you can see,
ensure that the right decisions
are being made all the time.
Now let's look at the
PDF it has generated.
So this is the PDF it generated.
Again, we will walk through the code now.
We just prompted the,
in the prompt of the supervisor agent,
we said, "Create a PDF
with all of these details,"
and it automatically created all of these.
It gives all of the information
for the underwriter,
like what is the credit risk assessment,
what's the compliant validation,
what are the next steps?
All of those things,
it will be there in the PDF,
and the underwriter can use this
to make their decisions very quickly.
Now, any questions on the solution?
Go ahead, please.
- [Audience Member] How do you
guys prevent prompt injection
for the upload of documents?
How do you ensure that those
documents don't have any
sort of injection prompts in
them to attack your model?
- [Murali] That's a good question.
So as Mrudhula explained earlier,
all of these agents use A2A protocol,
and all of them use OAuth authentication.
So within the OAuth authentication,
when these agents wants to
communicate with each other,
only if they have the right token,
they would be able to communicate
and access those functionalities.
Any other external,
if some other agent wants to
interact with these agents,
as you said, to do a prompt injection,
that would not be possible.
- [Mrudhula] So I'll add to that.
That's because that's a
very important question.
So we haven't used that in
this specific solution per se,
but this is what you can do
to make sure that you don't have issues
with prompt injection
or any other any of the
OWASP agentic AI risks
and how to mitigate them, right?
So on that main.
So, Strands Agents is the one
that we are using here.
That supports Guardrails.
So if you're familiar with
Amazon Bedrock Guardrails,
it's essentially a capability
where you can specify
automated reasoning checks,
grounded checks, denied topics,
which is more around the
question that's being asked.
Moderate content, things like that.
All of those filters can be
something that you can associate
with the guardrail,
and that guardrail
itself can be associated
with the model that is used in
the definition of your agent.
So as we go into the code,
I can show you the exact lines
of code where you can
associate a guardrailed model
in the agent itself.
So that is supported.
- [Murali] Awesome.
- [Mrudhula] Yes.
- [Audience Member] There's a lot
of numbers here that are
needing to be very accurate.
How are you passing the extraction tool
and several agents in the way
with several different calls.
How are you ensuring
that the data that's extracted
is what the models are seeing
from each of those individual calls?
Is that some stored
memory somewhere, or like,
how are you actually relying
or making sure that those
numbers are accurate
by the time it gets to
the supervisor agent?
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, great question.
And I think that also leads
into kind of the auditability
of this solution, right?
Yeah.
So when we talked about the
Bedrock Data Automation,
the BDA tool, which is the one,
the workhorse that's actually
looking at the documents,
extracting the information,
giving you the probabilities
for all of that,
all of that data,
extracted data gets persisted
inside object store, S3.
So long after the process is done,
that data is still there
for you to look at anytime
by your regulators,
your compliance officers, anybody,
and that then becomes the source.
So the agents are simply just doing the,
kind of the back and forth of,
- [Murali] Orchestration.
- [Mrudhula] Orchestration.
They encapsulate your business logic,
but the data itself is
persisting in that object store.
- [Murali] Now let's look at
how we build the solution.
And one of the first things I want
to mention is we built all
of the solution using Kiro Agentic IDE.
So using Kiro, we worked with Kero,
you can call Kiro as one of our members.
It helped us build out this whole solution
in a very quick manner.
- [Mrudhula] So shall I do this?
- [Murali] Yes.
- [Mrudhula] How many of you
have played with Kiro before?
Have you even heard of it?
Okay.
- [Murali] Just give me a second.
So let me.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah.
So this is our latest agentic coding tool.
It's agentic AI IDE,
essentially standalone.
It's built from the ground up.
It's not a plugin into any IDE,
like Q Developer you might have heard of.
This is kind of a standalone IDE,
and it's really good at
spec-driven development.
So we used the IDE for developing this.
So I wanted to show you
the spec-driven
development pretty briefly.
Okay.
So unlike vibe coding,
any vibe coders here?
Everybody?
Nope, nope, no vibe coders, okay.
I thought if you didn't raise a hand,
that means everybody's a vibe coder.
No worries.
So Kiro supports vibe coding,
but we are not just
looking at POCs, right?
We are looking at
how do you build an
enterprise-grade application.
So we are following a
very rigorous process
of using spec-driven development.
And what I'm showing you
here are the assets of that,
essentially your requirements,
your design, and your tasks,
so you can implement the solution.
So part of the requirements, it's,
essentially the entire SDLC, right?
Starting with what are your user stories
and what are the requirements
associated with each of those.
So like we mentioned,
we wanted to use the A2A protocol.
That was our starting point
that was one of our main requirements.
So as a systems architect,
I want all my agents to
communicate using this protocol.
So, you know, a lot of requirements there.
Agent discovery, again,
this is based on Strand supports this.
AgentCore supports this using agent cards.
And then there's quite a bit.
It's pretty comprehensive,
but just for each of
the agents themselves,
they have very specific requirements.
Like the BDA agent has its own set
of acceptance criteria and so on.
And then going into the design,
the idea is measure
twice, cut once, right?
Make sure you come up with, you know,
the way we did this was we used Kiro,
gave a kind of a brief description
of the problem that we were solving.
And Kiro came up with all of these assets,
the requirements, design, and task.
But that's just the first draft.
It's a pretty iterative process,
so you can review what it comes up with,
then you can modify using
your natural language prompts.
So continue to define
the design until you get
to a state where this feels
like it's pretty close
to your use case.
And that's exactly what we did.
So it comes up with the
as-built architecture,
the loan request coming
to the supervisor agent,
which is then communicating using A2A
with all the specialized agents.
So lots of information
when you work through this
in terms of what the design should be,
and then into the tasks.
So these are tasks that you were,
it's doing the tasks in a phased manner,
starting with the infrastructure setup.
So this is infrastructure
beyond just AgentCore.
These are basic things like
setting up your S3 buckets,
right, which is where your input data,
so all your loan application forms,
all of those get stored,
as well as the data that's
extracted by Data Automation,
that gets persisted as well.
So getting all those buckets set up,
getting your OAuth set up.
So in our case, we used
Amazon Cognito for that.
You might have your own IDP that you want
to integrate with, right?
Like Okta or Entra ID and so on.
So getting that OAuth
set up is another piece
of getting ready to build a solution.
The other things are too is,
how do you store your secrets, right?
Like secrets manager,
that's a very important one.
And then your IAM roles, right,
your permissions that each
of your agents would have
to interact with other AWS services.
Then things like Amazon Bedrock Gateway,
AgentCore Gateway that I mentioned.
So that needs to get set up
so that you can then the agents
can then access the tools
that are targets behind
that AgentCore Gateway.
So some of that infrastructure
needs to be done upfront.
So that's phase one,
and then phase two is
essentially building all
of your agents and then deploying them
to AgentCore runtime,
which is your compute.
So a complete set of tasks
which then get checked off
as Kiro starts implementing your solution.
So just a structured approach
to having an end-to-end solution.
- [Murali] Awesome.
So now let me walk you
through how we build the supervisor agent.
So all of these agents,
we'll be explaining them basically
by breaking down into four sections.
The first section is what all
libraries you need to import.
Here we are saying, you know,
"You need to import the
Strands multi-agent A2A
from A2A servers," that
enables the A2A communication.
Then you also need to
import the A2A client
from the client tool provider
so that it is able to discover the agents.
Then we are also importing
the code interpreter
so that you can provide
as a tool to the agents.
And the other two libraries
are making sure, you
know, those are required
for running the A2A agent as servers.
Then we have the configuration
section where we configure
in a what's our AWS region,
what are the buckets we are using,
any other parameters we are using.
And we also have a code.
And this is only bit of
the code you would see
in all of this, where, you know,
how we are handling the OAuth
tokens between the agents.
When this agent needs to
communicate to another agent,
they need to have the
refreshed OAuth token.
And this part of the
code would handle that.
Again here as Mrudhula mentioned,
for the client ID client secret token URL
used for OAuth tokens,
we retrieve all of them
from the secrets manager
to make sure they are not exposed as well.
And this would be the main part
of the supervisor agent
which is the prompt.
In the prompt, we define what
is the role of the agent,
basically what task
it's going to be doing.
Then we are going to also
define how we are going
to be discovering the
other available agents,
what kind of tools you would be accessing
to discover the other agents.
Then we will also be defining like
as a standard operating procedure,
when you are selecting another agents,
what are the qualities
you need to look for
in those agents when you want to pass
on the tasks to them.
As an example, if you want to use an agent
for document validation,
then you need to ensure that
when you read the agent card it has words
like document, validation,
compliance, completeness, etc,
in their agent card.
So only use those agents
for document validation.
So here we are making sure
we are guiding the agents
to make sure they perform
the way we intend to.
Then we are also making sure
how agent communication,
as many of you ask questions,
how does agent know what
data comes back and forth?
How they would be interacting with other,
as an example, an ML model.
This is where we define what is the type
of output you would be expecting,
what is the type
of output you should be
sending to other agents.
We would be defining all
of these things here.
And then specifically for
credit risk assessment,
what you should make sure,
like one of the things,
we are ensuring
that you are passing the
entire validated data structure
to the credit risk assessment
so that whatever agent
is performing the credit risk assessment,
it has got all of the data.
Do not just truncate some of
the data and pass it across.
So these are the instructions
we provide to the agent.
And finally, we also
provide the decision logic.
How it has to say if a loan
application is approved
or manual review or rejected,
what is the decision logic
is it needs to follow.
Then after completing it,
we are saying, "Once you create your,
you have your decision,
then use the tool to make a PDF report."
And we are just specifying
what information must be there
in the PDF report,
and what are the PDF report
requirements we are specifying.
Then we are saying, "Upload
it to an S3 bucket."
We are saying which bucket you
should need to upload it to.
Then we are saying where
you should send an email to.
Because this is a demonstration
system, we built out,
we made sure that all
of the emails go to
just one email address.
But in a real-world scenario,
you can specify that
pick up the email address
from the loan application
or from the conversation
you had with the applicant,
then send that response
back to that email.
It would go ahead and do that.
And you would also want
to say how you want
your email to look like.
What is the formatting, all of those.
Now, again, one of the
key advantages of this is
if tomorrow a requirement changes,
all you would have to do is
come back and change the prompt,
which is very easy to do
because this is more like
natural language where you define
in your own natural language saying
what you want the agent to do,
rather than having it as written as a code
and maintaining the code,
just come and change the prompt here.
It can quickly adapt to your
changing business requirements.
- [Audience Member] I
have one more question.
(audience member murmuring)
Is the outcome also is the
same for the next time?
Maybe the first one is like this,
but is there any guarantee
deterministic that the output
for the second one will be the same?
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, so yeah,
you're basically bringing out
the non-deterministic nature
of these agents, right?
However, in this case,
provided in this case your
inputs are still the same.
It's the same set of documents,
and the logic inside each of
these agents, like for example,
the calculation of credit worthiness,
whatever business logic you have
inside the credit risk agent, for example,
those are still pretty deterministic
because those are just
mathematical calculations.
So the agents themselves are,
it's not like a text-based prediction.
Yes, you're using a lot of
prompts to drive the work,
but you are under the hood
in those prompts being very specific.
And this is where like we
were mentioning the SOPs,
the operating procedures,
come into play, right?
As long as you have that
clearly defined in the prompts,
the calculations will follow,
and then the results of those
are still deterministic.
And so the input stays the same,
the data extracted stays the same.
And as long as the,
even with like the data
BDA tool that you're using
for extracting data from each of those,
for each of those documents,
if you're still keeping
that same threshold,
the data that's input
into those downstream
mathematical calculations
still is the same, right?
So you should not see for
example something flip
from an approval to a
denial kind of thing.
- [Murali] And as a best practice.
Yeah, go ahead please.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah.
(audience member murmuring)
- [Audience Member] So how
do you expect this solution
like digital business
would work differently,
that says, oh, today I'm
taking 3% of the earning.
That's my mistake, right?
That's a business question.
How would that?
- [Murali] So if I understand
your question right,
you today you may have a DTI requirement,
tomorrow you have another DTI requirement.
How you would want to adapt that?
As you know, all you
can go at is, you know,
can change in your system prompt.
How would you want the
decisioning logic to be done on
based on the DTI?
- [Audience Member] How do you do the DTI?
I don't see any here documentation.
- [Murali] Yes, yes.
- [Audience Member] Is this a requirement?
(audience member murmuring)
But I'm not seeing a lot
of business requirement.
- [Murali] Yeah.
So the DTI prompts,
that is not how it calculates the DTI.
That is in the compliance
validation agent.
That's where it
is calculating the DTI
using the code interpreter.
There you can define how you
want the DTI to be calculated.
The supervisor agent, in this,
the supervisor agent is
just playing the role
of an orchestrator where
it is passing information
to all of these other agents
who have their tasks clearly defined.
As you said, for the DTI agent,
it'll be the compliance
agent where, you know,
you will have the prompt defining how you
are calculating the DTI
using the code interpreter,
and there you can define
your thresholds there.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, I think we
haven't shown that piece yet,
but there's a specialized agent
and the prompt which captures that, yep.
Yes.
- [Audience Member] So
designing a system like this,
how do you recommend
evaluating model accuracy
between the different models
if you were to switch out
for let's say a newer model?
- [Murali] That's a good question.
In Bedrock, we have something
called as model evaluation,
where before you start
building these solutions,
you can start evaluating a model.
There are two types of
model evaluations we offer.
One is we have curated data sets
where you use those curated data sets
to have the model run against them,
and you can see the accuracy,
or you can bring in your own data
and use it against those models
to see which one works best
and then use it in your system.
- [Mrudhula] So basically
it requires you to have some
kind of ground truth data,
something that you have historically
for similar profiles of customers,
what the loan decisioning has been.
And then there's definitely
a lot of work involved.
You need to set up that
evaluation harness on your end
so that when you deploy
these kinds of systems,
you have something, some
kind of gold standard
to compare to the results
that are coming out of it.
And that, we can't emphasize enough
the importance of testing,
especially with these
non-deterministic applications.
- [Audience Member] Is
that framework something
that you would build
into this application
or even run separately?
- [Mrudhula] So we have,
I haven't gone through
the entire task list,
but in the design itself,
some of the aspects of that
design include testing,
that's end-to-end testing.
So that includes unit
testing, integration testing,
all of that.
And if you have specific evaluation
like metrics and things like that,
and a source of data
that you can point to,
all of that can be incorporated as well.
- [Audience Member] Have
you used any pattern
to ground the image like
reflection, how do we use it?
- [Mrudhula] Like design patterns?
So we are in this case using
the Strands A2A design pattern.
It's pretty standard.
Strands also supports others like workflow
which are more deterministic.
The graph-based design,
like graph as in like each
of these specialized agents
can be nodes,
and you can have
essentially like in a graph,
you can have edges connect between,
if you think of each of
the agents as being a node,
the communication between them is an edge.
So you can define what
that multi-agent structure
needs to look like in a graph.
So that is one of the
other design patterns
that's supported natively
by Strands agents.
A2A is, it's a more flexible
based on agent discovery
that we are using.
But you know, this is one
of the design patterns that's supported
inside Strands framework as well.
Yeah.
(audience member murmuring)
- [Mrudhula] Like the
React pattern, right?
Yeah.
- [Murali] These use the React part
where they do the reasoning
and an actioning of it
where they reason that
given I have this task of,
as a supervisor agent,
his task is I have to process
these loan applications
and I have a set of tools to me,
and they use a reasoning
to create a workflow,
then use available tools,
the agents and the code
interpreter, to perform the tasks.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah.
Are you validating the Strand?
- [Murali] Yes.
- [Mrudhula] So I think the best way
to get to your question
is so reflection, right?
So this is based on the model
capability as well, you know.
So in this case the model
that we are using is
Anthropic's Claude Sonnet 4.5
which is very capable of reflection.
So it's built into,
so that's the one that's the brains
behind each of these agents.
As newer models come along
that can support even
more advanced deflection
or additional patterns, you can have,
like I was saying,
these AgentCore Strands,
they're all model agnostic.
Each agent can essentially
you can use a bedrock model
or you can use an open-source model,
and each agent can use a different model.
It doesn't have to be the same model.
So it's inbuilt
into the agent itself based
on the model selection.
- [Murali] That's a good segue.
The last fourth section
which we wanted to show
in the code is after the prompts
is how we are defining the agent here.
If you're looking at
here we define the agent,
what is the name of the agent,
the description of the agent,
the system prompt which is
the system prompt we saw
in detail, and as Mrudhula mentioned,
the model which is agnostic.
Again you can choose what
model works best for you
and you can have that model here.
And the tools are all the
tools like agent discovery
and the code interpreter tools.
And finally we have the agent
running as an A2A server.
So that way each of these agents,
they use a two-way communication to
between them whenever
they want to communicate.
The advantage of using
an A2A communication
is tomorrow you may have another
agents which is not running
on AgentCore but still
using A2A communications.
These agents running
on AgentCore can communicate
with them as well.
- [Mrudhula] Yes.
(audience member murmuring)
- [Mrudhula] The data the that's
passed between the agents.
Yeah.
So in this case
since we're using A2A, it's
a JSON RPC message format.
And so this is, the output
of one agent gets passed
in that format, the JSON
RPC format, to the agent,
like the supervisor agent, for example.
So that message body
contains all the information.
That's basically the input
that's needed by the next agent.
- [Murali] All of these
agents uses HTTPs protocol.
So all of those,
whenever they are
communicating between them,
even when they are
communicating this JSON data
between them, they are all encrypted.
(audience member murmuring)
- [Mrudhula] Yeah.
And there is on the OAuth
happening every step of the way.
So the OAuth setup that we used
at the beginning that I was talking
about using Cognito, that
you know, you're using.
So yeah, this is a very important piece
that we probably haven't mentioned yet,
is when you deploy your agent,
you configure the OAuth,
the auth configuration
for each of those agents.
So you can have something like IAM SigV4
if you're familiar with that.
That's the default,
but it also supports OAuth 2.0.
So in this case, every
agent that we deploy,
there is a configuration
that needs to happen
and we set that up as
like a JWT custom token.
So every single one
of those agent interactions is
authenticated and authorized.
Yeah.
- [Murali] I think you had
one question we'll take.
Yes.
(audience member murmuring)
- [Mrudhula] Correct, yes.
- [Mrudhula] No, correct.
(audience member murmuring)
- [Mrudhula] So RBAC control, you said?
- [Mrudhula] So these are
tools behind the gateway.
Are you referring to the
tools behind the gateway?
Yes.
So the agent itself.
So in this case, for
example, the BD agent,
the data extraction agent
that's actually calling the making that,
we set up what is called
an MCP client on the agent.
So the agent is acting as your MCP client,
and then it's communicating
with the AgentCore gateway,
which is that MCP server.
And behind that you have
essentially a lambda
that's making an API call to Bedrock BDA.
So the communication between
the NCP client and gateway is,
it's an OAuth 2 authentication
and authorization as well.
And then behind that,
it's all IAM permissions.
So that's where RBAC comes in.
Yeah.
Yes.
- [Audience Member]
Here you have mentioned
like all the tools in the single agent.
So I have experience,
like if we provide more than
like 40 tools or something.
Agent gets started confusing,
like between choosing each of the tools.
- [Mrudhula] Correct.
Yeah.
You want to talk about
the semantic search?
- [Murali] Yes.
So one of the ones we have in
Agent Gateway is what we call
as a semantic search.
And as you said, giving
agent more than 40 tools,
and it does not decide what tools to use.
There are two things.
One is making sure our
prompt is very clear
of what our requirements are
so that it specifically knows
what the task it has got
and then it can search the right tool.
And AgentCore gateway
supports something called
as a semantic search.
In this case, when we say the BDA,
when the Bedrock Data Automation agent,
when it has to do a data extraction,
it first does a semantic
search like data extraction.
What tools are there
available for data extraction?
And then the gateway
returns available tools
which are there for data extraction.
Then it chooses that and
perform the data extractions.
In your case, if you have
got more than 40 tools,
you can have it behind a
gateway, AgentCore gateway,
and then the agent can
do a semantic search
based on the task what it wants.
Then the AgentCore gateway
will return maybe out
of 40 tools, maybe 10 tools.
And then out of those 10 tools,
the AgentCore is then able to,
the agent is able to select the right tool
to perform the task.
- [Mrudhula] Yeah, and I'll add
that really the best
practice is you want to think
of the agent as being
a microservice, right,
essentially that same mindset.
So depending on it's
definitely purpose built
for that business function.
So you want to give it the
tools only that it needs
and only the permissions that
it needs for those tools.
So you know, you don't
want to have 40 tools,
for example, the specialized
agencies especially should only
have a couple of tools, two,
three tools that it really
needs to get the job done.
In the supervisor agent,
this is accumulating, because it's trying
to help the specialized agents figure out
which tools to use.
It's listing them, but the
supervisor agent itself
is not ready calling those tools.
So there's a little.
It's different, right?
So but yes, that's a very good point.
You know, you need to
have purpose built agents
and just the tools that they need.
- [Murali] We just have one
and a half minutes left,
so I'll just walk through one more agent
and any other questions, we are available
outside the room to take them as well.
- [Mrudhula] Actually we
can just wrap and go to the.
- [Murali] I just wanted
to quickly showcase the
compliance agent, the prompt,
and show you know how it is doing
the debt to income ratio.
You would see in the prompt here.
It's using the code
interpreter to perform these.
And tomorrow if your
business requirement changes,
you can come here and change
it in the prompt itself.
It's not the supervisor agent
which is doing that.
Here we have purpose built agents
for each of these functions.
And when you want to change
any of these functions,
you can come to those purpose built agents
and change the prompt there,
and your newer business
logic would come into play.
- [Mrudhula] And do you want to show them
a code that they can go to?
We want to give you something actionable
so that as you walk out of the room today,
you have something to go build.
So we have a couple of official repos.
One is the Strands Agents
itself which contains,
it's a GitHub repo
that contains all the
different design patterns
that you can build with.
A2A is one of them that we used
for today's solution.
And then another official GitHub repo
for Bedrock AgentCore.
It's a really rich set of code samples.
We based a lot of our solution
based on those code samples
that are in Bedrock AgentCore repo.
So please use those.
They just accelerate your
entire development process.
These are vetted solutions
meant for building secure,
scalable agentic AI application.
So go have fun with those,
and definitely give Kiro a try.
It's been very helpful for us.
- [Murali] And thank you.
Thank you so much for listening to us.
Hope you liked this.
(audience applauding)
And we are available outside
the room for any questions.